I just saw our the cap with a with a
shirt you better not let Tracy Morgan
wearing that you just realized what you
were wearing by looking into the screen
I found out I'll get my hat and my strip
back
hello everyone hola Mis Amigos you're
listening to oh my God
With Me George Lopez foreign
you know George is oh I'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
George Robert George Lopez oh my God OMG
OMG oh my God
hey so what's up man you want to be or
what no I can't drink a beer I'm the dog
said week two weeks no alcohol whatever
whatever well I had a bleeding ulcer
they had to go back inside me put some
chicken in there Patch It Up kick my ass
out send me home so this is Aaron's
guitar I'm gonna sing a song and he just
said no spice yeah in English
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
so you can only drink water why can I
use it
[Music]
yeah he said he said just drink water
week two weeks no alcohol he said no
spice food no alcohol so uh that he said
A week two weeks that's for regular
people what's that for Mexican three
days well by Next by next Thursday I'll
be back with you
hmm
what's going on
nothing I'm just attacking the world can
you you said you were spent a couple
days in the hospital yeah yeah I went
there went in there Saturday uh Sunday
did nothing but lay around on my ass uh
Monday they rolled me on in knocked my
ass out that profile's good stuff it is
good yeah they knocked my ass out but
you know you can't do it at home because
you'll die but yeah at home hey I wish
I'd had my Michael Jackson glove out of
pants what if they had a [ __ ] yeah
uh
listen you so so you're a big dude
you've been to Vietnam you've been
around the world a few times imagine
that propofol couldn't knock Michael
Jackson out and he had to be like a
hundred and I don't know man 40 pounds
maybe yeah I can't post up his immune
system I know last time here he is last
time I did it the anesthesiologist Asian
guy come up he says oh you big oh you
real big
but he didn't give me enough [ __ ] I
still woke up during the procedure hey
uh welcome man yeah sorry Bill hey
Jeremiah nice to meet you this guy you
know there's a lot of Jeremiah's out
there there's not a lot that are born
and raised in California right but
Jeremiah is is it a Biblical name yeah
it's also an African-American I met a
lot of ones how many jeremius Watkins
yes but uh oh do you know how many times
I've been confused for a black guy like
right before like oh like a black guy
who was bringing up the next comic is
like who's gonna bring it up Jeremiah
Watkins and then they're disappointed
when they see a white guy that's
hilarious yeah yeah uh do you know Gil
Gil Korea just matters right now long
time friends yeah yeah uh nice shirt oh
thank you establish the comments toward
night who was the first comedian to ever
step on stage of The Comedy Store
uh I don't know I don't know if it was
Sammy Shore Sammy Shore and then also I
don't know I'm trying to think of the
the other person who would be so so
um
you how does it go so you know it's
always interesting to see how guys find
their way to Comedy yeah yeah but are
you musical as well too right yeah and
you act I play sax yeah yeah yeah I just
heard you played sex yeah yeah okay so
in school did you pick up an instrument
I did I played like and some like just
kind of grade school band like very
early on like third fourth grade you
know what I think is a bad what I think
is a bad thing for schools is that they
don't offer music anymore as as a choice
like you have to get music on your own
but if you went to Junior High in
seventh grade you could you could take
music and then get an instrument you
used to have to do it you had to had to
and maybe some kids weren't musicians
and maybe some were but you found out
quick you found out quick let's try
started Elementary School yeah the only
thing I ever asked my dad for that I
really didn't need
and he rented a saxophone for me [ __ ]
hey man yeah he did what kind of sex we
talking Alto dinner Alto when I by the
time I got to high school I was blown
tenor yeah and now in old age I picked
up the berry ah
what's the bear from the doctor no I
want it because
he's because he's leaving for his butt
yeah
hey man
have you ever had an ulcer no not yet
don't you don't want you don't want one
right I had one and it doubled me over I
got it on the road I went on a bus tour
the first year of my show I thought you
know I'll be cool by doing that that
[ __ ] thing it it hurts doesn't it no
it didn't hurt at all they kept saying
does it hurt no it doesn't hurt I'm fine
Nothing Hurt other than the blood coming
out you know and that didn't hurt hey
did you buy that [ __ ] hat in that
shirt in the same bag no no no I didn't
but it's a Costco sometimes it has it
but hey you get the shirt you go egg oh
guess what a [ __ ] hat two [ __ ] when I
when I came in the pocket
I have all my hats in the same place
why not ah
God damn it took you long wow
when was that that was for my 70th
birthday
it was two years ago Oh I thought you
didn't play anymore yeah that was the
last time I played oh man after that
that's when I had uh since then I had uh
lung surgery
and they took off six inches of my right
lung and I'm still having fluid in there
and things getting heavy I'm getting old
welcome to the show man yeah hey he's
got big lungs
and then oil the fancy blood
first of all who's musical in your
family
has to be I always think genetics do you
think genetics play a part in I think in
some families for sure but my mom and my
dad can't really sing yeah they can't
really sing they can't carry too much of
a tune so I think that uh uh and even my
grandma and my grandpa I'll just hear
them like singing in church and stuff
but they'd always sing low enough where
you couldn't pick up really you know
like like so other people would be
masking their voices yeah yeah so you uh
uh and uh when did you start to feel
that like in elementary school junior
high yeah I I I started one of those I
started this is late laughter I'm still
laughing at him when I was looking for
the photo he's making fun I just saw it
on the cap with a with a shirt hey you
better not let Tracy Morgan you just
realized what you were wearing by
looking into the screen I found out I'll
get my hat and my shirt back
that's my Tracy Morgan that's actually
pretty good I hung out with him for a
while he don't remember because it was
actually the accident oh okay he really
doesn't remember he looks like he got an
accident wearing that that [ __ ] what
are you running through
I had the shirt and then I just I have
my hats all the same place there's some
plaid shirts there's that planet put
your flat head on
you know what if you went to Griffith
Park wearing that with a red bandana I
wouldn't stick it out of your back
pocket if I went to Griffith Park you'd
be you'd be working it right now if you
get all kinds of oil oh yeah they'd be
filling you in yeah
this is how the old lady likes me to
wear it [ __ ] it baby because she says
the other way I look too old [ __ ]
all right they're all right you do look
more Jazzy this way versus the front way
does look you know it is a different
vibe there it is and if you ever want to
go to a job interview and not get it put
it sideways
uh um um what do you like no no we're
still with the with the music oh but
what do you feel like you you I found
out kind of like in grade school like
when you we had to start doing quite you
know they forced us to do choir and ban
and stuff early on and I just had a
knack for it I had a good year for it
and uh I started getting told that I had
a good singing voice uh like early on
and my mom would tell me she would
always she was she's always been very
encouraging of like my musicality yeah
yeah wow man that's awesome yeah
you could you sing or you just I I sang
but not no no classes no nothing I
always want to sing with the band when I
was young what did you want to see that
could be
on a desert yeah lost without a place to
go but we're so in love in love with
each other and blood's coming out of my
oil
I don't care I don't care that I can't
sit down anywhere
that's his life everywhere it's not like
you know it's like you know if you if
somebody's next door to the hospital
they go we have to give them his last
rights and they're watching cartoons in
the next one
I'd make ombre over here
and what music did you like growing up
uh I grew up on oldies uh classic rock
uh we had Mo and and randomly it was
like in the 90s boy bands were huge so
like we'd have different CDs in the car
my mom had best of Steve Miller Band
Fleetwood Mac Oh uh uh we had like the
Beatles Anthology discs that we would
put in and then uh then it was like
Backstreet Boys very polarizingly
different yeah you know genres of music
but do you think you think the boy band
craze like
did it help music because those guys
didn't play they sang right right so
it's really kind of a throwback to the
50s like of the Four Tops or the
Spinners and the shy lights just another
version of it where the guys didn't come
out with instruments you know
um it got young girls into it right into
music well the K like K-pop is
essentially a bunch of boy bands now and
that's like bigger than any kind of
music why is K-pop bigger than regular
pop because chinitos that is uh Global
because half an hour later you want to
hear music again
foreign
you know man when you're racist it's
hard to stop being racist
you know people look at racism Martinez
about it
what the [ __ ] is going hey how about how
about how racist I love this guy how
racist
where they know they're being recorded
they're talking [ __ ] that guy that that
Jewish son of a [ __ ] it's like it's
like what the [ __ ] you know you're being
recorded and it doesn't matter yeah it
still doesn't matter
I knew that girl that that Nuri her
sister was the councilwoman yeah
well I'll suck your dick
George can you write a a jingle for us
sure how long does that to be uh like
five seconds before your vote
take it easy you're scaring our guessing
no I love you scared of [ __ ] me then
um and uh um
I see that I know there's so many things
I want to ask you uh you have children I
do I've got a son he's a year and a half
now yeah yeah yeah
um and where did you meet your wife I
met my wife doing improv at Second City
out here in La actually oh wow yeah yeah
tell me about that yeah we were both
taking classes uh you didn't know her
from anywhere right no first time you
saw her she was in your class yeah yeah
we uh she grew up in the Bay Area and
she came down here uh in her 20s uh she
was doing acting stuff and I was doing
the comedy thing and and I was taking
them for that and she ended up using the
Improv classes she teaches kids uh um on
the Spectrum to help with their social
skills and emotional skills uh through
improv now and I use in my improv for
within my stand-up and different stuff
like that wait a minute so
you know the Spectrum right no where the
Sixers played in the in the 70s no uh
the spectrum is can we explain the a
spectrum to uh Gill yeah whether you're
on or off the autism spectrum or you
have different special needs where you
help uh need help with communicating or
even eye contact it can be some kids are
like non-verbal where they have trouble
communicating uh with their mouth and
they literally need help just like
communicating with eyes or their hands
or anything and she's used improv games
and developed a curriculum around that
to help kids wow yeah yeah so she's a
social emotional learning specialist now
at uh at a charter school here in L.A
are children being born with with that
kind of emotional
um where what would it be called
emotional what's is it not an issue no
no
um but are kids being born where they're
have trouble when they start to talk
that they have trouble communicating
talking oh sure yeah there's a lot of uh
kids on on the spectrum that are born
non-verbal where they have problem
communicating their needs even like with
just what they can speak they can speak
they can't speak but there's there's um
just something in their brain that's
holding them back from uh completing
that thought or their their needs okay
check this out so this is what's going
on with kids now if we went to school
and a kid didn't talk right and they
would say David tuck he doesn't talk
about mom telling you give me your
[ __ ] Bell he'll talk right now
right can't you just see give me the
chat I can just see right parents being
mean to a kid that's non-verbal oh yeah
yeah because you don't unders you don't
you wouldn't understand why he's not
talking you know oh he thinks he's
better than us
that's why he doesn't talk and they whip
your ass man oh yeah I think that that's
right oh no it's been around for a long
time it's been handled differently yeah
yeah and and what is it is that a
um is it genetic is it Pastor the
parents is it uh some of yeah some of it
is uh genetic
um what they found um I'm definitely not
an expert
from from what I understand yeah and the
Improv helps them it yeah like through
like different games and stuff like that
it helps them get out of their comfort
zone uh or it breaks it down in a way
where they uh just have to focus on the
thing that's right in front of them so
they end up becoming more comfortable
with other things in life after they
kind of conquer these little games yeah
could have been brought on by a
traumatic experience you know watching
you know if there was domestic violence
in the house before them when they were
little uh I mean that's that's uh not
the Spectrum I mean that's that's
probably something that's uh that's
other yeah uh but but I'm sure like
these games like help in those
situations and I wonder what it I mean I
don't remember
um
again I'm not an expert clearly but I
don't remember as many kids who were
either
um in a slow not emotional classes in
our in elementary school and Junior High
yeah not as many where I think you might
see more more now oh yeah it's just a
different like but is it what we're
eating is it is I don't think I just
recognize yeah I just think it's
something that was recognized when we
were younger you know that I think he
was just like oh that kid's different
you know what I mean that's how it was
like like because autism wasn't like as
well known like even when I was I had a
joke about Latinos where they were they
have three kids but one of them is
Autistic so you'll never see that one so
they come over they go where your kids
at no they're right here I only have two
I thought you had three and I had two in
the back here
tell your brother to shut up more people
over there right now
one more time he's gonna be yelling for
real
in the back because you know we we were
not
um
we we would hide those people it was I
think right yeah well
I just think you just the longest game
of hide and seek ever yeah keep keep
hiding keep hiding you know and it's not
I mean it's mean but I mean it's I ask
if it's traumatic because my
granddaughter who had traveled with the
team dancing around the world she was in
she went to Japan
and this was a year and a half after the
they had the big tsunami that wiped
everything out one they used to work
with little kids and teaching them how
to dance and there was this little
little boy that had not spoken in over a
year and a half since a tsunami and not
spoken and he finally broke out and
started communicating with my
granddaughter
he said
he said
I don't know how you get to go over
there
no I can't imagine a tsuna I mean
here if it rains you spin out you know
because after the first rain of the
season but imagine you know the trauma
of tsuna yeah in La when it drops five
degrees I need a scarf yeah you know
what I mean I need a beanie oh my God
I'm not gonna go I don't want to get my
car wet right that's like that that was
my excuse one time
um and then you guys started what was it
when you saw your wife for the first
time I was like okay I kind of see it I
can feel it
well she had a boyfriend like when I
first saw her and I was like about my
comedy so I was like okay cool but then
I found out she didn't have a boyfriend
then I was like okay hey we should hang
out and then that would you say we
should hang out yeah yeah I was like I
messaged her I was like hey we should
hang out sometime pretty direct yeah and
she said yeah cool and then yeah and
then eventually we went on one date I
kissed her at the end of that first day
and I thought it was great she called me
the next day she's like I think we
should just be friends oh [ __ ] and I was
like oh I go I just stayed chill I was
like all right that's that's okay for
now
wow man so you know that's one way of
doing it well you know I think most guys
either confident or serial killer you
know we're back to licking you read yeah
yeah yeah right back to it I'm
practicing for the next time is that
what you got to do was there a way to
lick a reed that was different than
everybody else that just soaked that
they get it you got to soak it get it
nice and what's the bamboo is the Reed
of the sex is it bamboo they have most
of them are bamboo they also have
fiberglass ones that I never could play
with I've never played that yeah I play
with the wood and where does the Reed go
on your tongue and then it goes you're
biting onto the mouthpiece and then
you're you're cupping your under lip and
then yeah so it's who the [ __ ] who
designs that [ __ ] instrument
okay get get some of that tree like
about this long
I'm gonna put it here you're gonna blow
from under you blow from under But first
you gotta suck it real good wow yeah
yeah it's real thin so it'll vibrate
yeah that's what it sounds like yeah
that's the sound
wow so it's so I think it's amazing for
anybody to blow into it much less create
music from sure from blowing into a reed
how long did you play for when you
played ah no I was never a great player
I played tenor I started in elementary
school through high school right after
high school I went in the Army and then
I came back played a couple of gigs but
I in my high school days I was playing
they they asked me to audition for rock
and roll band I started playing with
rock and roll but that was the easiest
thing to do in the world you know it was
easy to do so as a kid I'm making 10 to
25 bucks an hour doing something that I
love to do and so it was cool could you
play shotgun yeah Junior Walker that was
that what happened now if I gave you
your sacks right now and you tried to
play shotgun would your spine blow out
of your [ __ ] no man my blood would
blow out of my head you know
right no my fingers don't don't that's
why I went to the baritone because you
know you start off now though you went
with the thinner a lot of fingering
there baritone is the bottom it's like
the tuba of the band yeah the basement
so you're not blowing the base you're
blowing you're just not doing a lot of
intricate fingering right it's nice and
slow you know you
um so it's just the bottom end of the
group you should look up a sax player
who plays baritone that is one of the
fastest players I've ever seen his name
is Leo P phenomenal saxophonist yeah you
would he would blow your mind the sounds
that he can make with a baritone he
makes it go really high he makes it go
crazy and you don't you don't hear that
that often yeah the sax player uh DOC
for uh
[ __ ]
come on man don't be broken
some old [ __ ] no no he's a big band
from San Francisco area uh
oh that'll narrow it down yeah okay okay
laid out go [ __ ] it out there and lay
down come back in here where you can
talk like a normal person you've been
playing guitar for a while uh uh no I
play every day
that kind of it sounds like I can play
but I think prac he's missing a string
oh God
the beam you're just a young man that's
a big you're still a young man Tower
Power of power they're they're Barry sax
player is good gotcha
oh that's fine oh sorry never mind
that's wait what was my separate song
ringtone
yeah
can you hear it yep all right I thought
I was going crazy because I heard sax I
was like yeah
um why sex why sax
I saw somebody playing it and it just
was one of those instruments that right
away it fascinated me and I was like I
want to play that I asked my mom and dad
I was like can I can can we figure out a
way and I started taking lessons you
said that could you figure out could we
figure out a way to yeah can I can I can
I play that and then I started working
like odd jobs and stuff when we rented
this old Yamaha from the music shop
started taking lessons from this music
shop and then like I'd mow Lawns shovel
drives and put money towards paying off
the sacks and then like birthdays and
stuff like that I'd ask for money to pay
towards the sex yeah
you would appreciate this one of the
guys that was and I wouldn't come with
me well because you're not a sack player
you wouldn't understand this part the
guy that was working with me was a he
was uh two years older than I was in the
school but he used to warm up triple
tugging
he had a professional sack player Stan
sector was giving him less than Stan
secler had to quiz I can't teach this
kid anymore he had Perfect Pitch you
could honk your horn he can tell you
what note it was he went to audition for
the SC band he auditioned for them they
jumped up and started yelling Bravo
first as a freshman first seat
as a sax player and the only guy that I
cried for he I went to school I was in
the Army I was in Vietnam and they
notified me uh he couldn't afford
because he was from a single single
single parent couldn't afford the SC
stuff anymore uh there wasn't enough
money certainly paying for him but to
help the family out yeah he went into
the army and he went to uh
Fort Huachuca Arizona which was the head
of the USC U.S Army Band
and he went uh on a hike and he fell
over uh the cliffs yeah
Chris Hardy yeah I'll never forget the
guy nicest guy in the world was great
the the band teacher gave him the keys
keys of the uh class go in there and
just play yeah he'd go in there and play
he worked with a few of us he was just
good and nice nice guy and the week and
to warm up
triple tongue he met it's phenomenal he
was just good
yeah and and how deep does your music go
there too for the Jazz to like rock who
used it in rock Bruce Springsteen yeah
Clarence and uh yeah I mean a lot of I
uh for me personally I I never got good
enough where I was like really good at
jazz by any means I did like I got to a
place where I could I have a really good
ear for sax and music where uh if I hear
something I can transcribe it like I can
literally that's how I will like I'll if
I hear a song on the radio I can play it
on sax by listening to it and writing
down the notes and then I can
read off of you know what I mean give
them your give them your test I wish
interrogation test I I wish I could do
that so give me give them your
interrogation test oh remember the one
two two okay okay you talk about your
parents here you had to go to your mom
and dad and get this when you talk about
and your grandparents you didn't know if
they were musical not but when you talk
about your grandfather what's the first
thing comes to mind
uh World War II World War II yeah and
why World War II why does that pop to
mind because he has
um he had a restless leg syndrome where
he would always be moving his leg so
that was like kind of what I started to
associate with them every time I saw him
oh
he's visual
yeah yeah he sees his grandfather so the
detectives use questioning to find out
how whoever they're interrogating
processes their information
yeah 99 of the population is either
visual audio or kinesthetic
you know you're either seen or you
remember hearing them yell at your
grandmother yeah audio or God he was so
full lover until I saw him he gave me a
big hug he was always warm tell me so
you kind of study heartfelt yeah so uh
when I
when I am interviewing somebody as a
suspect I want to know
how my what I'm going to do where my
questions are going to go sure so I want
to find out what kind of person he is
there were therefore I direct my
questioning towards type person he is
okay so what are you when when like if
somebody did that with you have you ever
I'd probably say
kinesthetic and I'm a touchy you know
heartwarming type of guy yeah so I'd
probably say I'm kinesthetic you're good
to me but also yeah it's very emotional
yeah
I I start crying when people make fun of
blood coming out of my culo
at what point did you decide to to leave
Kansas and come to California
when I was uh 20 years old that's
[ __ ] insane man that's so young when
I was 20. I couldn't do it I couldn't
have done it
and you just and you drove out here you
had your car you drove out yeah I packed
up with my brother wow and uh my dad and
my brother helped me we crammed
everything I owned into my car and then
when my brother my brother was old
enough to run a U-Haul uh with me when
he came to uh so we went to like the
Goodwills and salvation armies around
town got like a bed off Craigslist got a
dresser drawers and stuff like that off
Goodwill and stuff like that and then I
had a Craigslist roommate uh when that
was real popular like that's how I found
my place [ __ ] Craigslist what was
that like uh he was the dirtiest person
I've ever met in my life oh [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah what would he do just dishes
everywhere and that kind of thing and I
can't I'm very and what is that about
somebody man that just they not me a kid
what is that what do you cook like meat
like shirtless in the kitchen you know
stuff like that yeah and what did he do
for a living
he was just going to school I think he
became a lawyer
yeah yeah but just nasty right now
yeah he had a hot girlfriend it made no
sense it made no sense whatsoever he was
like a pig but like yeah had a hot
girlfriend did never added up to me you
looked at Craigslist you found the saw
the ad you called him up he said hey I'm
new in town I'm gonna go over there you
met him yeah there's a room that was
open there's another guy uh I had an
Indian roommate for a little bit I'd
never had Indian food before and he
would cook in the kitchen and I was
blown away by that it went to Indian
restaurants and stuff like that me from
Kansas like yeah very limited on like
the different like you know yeah
different ethnic regions and stuff like
that we just had like decent Mexican
food in Kansas City and uh like I had
like sushi like one time but like when I
moved to LA that's when I like started
trying everything Ethiopian Thai food
yeah Japanese food yeah and when you
moved out here you were moving out to do
comedy to sing or to do comedy wow man
yeah you went to The Comedy Store when
you were 20. uh when so I went to The
Comedy Store like one time for their
open mic when I was 21 and then I was
like I'm not ready yet I sensed that I
wasn't ready I was like this is the big
leagues like I gotta so I went and
worked on material until I had a bunch
of material built up because they're
open mic there they're potluck it's a
three minute set when you go up there
and and I wanted to do a different new
three minutes every time to make sure I
wowed the town coordinator there yeah
[ __ ] hey man we didn't do that
um
and it's and it was three minutes back
then it doesn't it doesn't seem like a
long time
but it can be oh if you're bombing
that's a long time you're eating yeah
it's been a [ __ ] long time yeah
but if it's going well you're just like
but you saw it as an occupation huh oh
always yeah I've been very always
focused as far as that and did you work
during the day while you while you got
out here in the first two and a half
years I was a Starbucks working at
Starbucks in Beverly Hills
wow man worst job I've ever had yeah how
come easily the worst clientele ever
[ __ ] people what are they rude and
they're like is this everything
imaginable the they they think of you so
like is that in your act
a little bit a little bit but I mean I
think people I think if you look for
stuff that people would laugh at sure
the relatability of doing an impression
of someone who's like
um this isn't what they're what were
their what were their top three
complaints be I mean I we had down to
the temperature
um excuse me this is not 140 degrees I
know what 140 degrees tastes like
like
like down to that kind of person
see how hot it is up there right wow man
this isn't 140 degrees I know what 140
degrees taste like yeah
yeah so I mean just very high
maintenance people and I luckily worked
with people who were very nice who there
are some girls that were Angels there
they said as long as you're making us
laugh we don't care how slow you are wow
yeah because it's about getting people
their drinks because it's like 6 a.m and
people are on their way to work and
they're all right can somebody make I
mean what I was so slow there they
thought I have special needs the
customers it was bad I said oh it's a
wonderful you hire them it was they're
like oh you're doing a good thing
but how fast do they expect is there is
the the Starbucks have a chart of what
somebody should take I think most people
expect to get their drinks in under two
minutes God damn under two minutes so
like me I was so bad at the job I'd be
sweating and nervous and stuff like that
because I knew that I wasn't I just
wasn't fast that's not like one of my
skill sets there was girls there that
could just they would whip up lattes so
fast you have to put a new lot that
thing they put in there and they pack it
you have to do a new one every time you
make a latte you gotta steam milk with
and you got to clean the espresso maker
and like add shots and stuff and it's
it's a it's a system where if you get it
down like a rhythm I could just never
get that like I also didn't like the job
so that didn't help right but you stayed
there for a couple of years because
they're flexible with my comedy wow I
gotta ask for to switch shifts with
people I was like hey I got a late show
on Tuesday can you cover for me like on
Wednesday or if I had an audition come
up then I could always swap shifts and
stuff like that wow man yeah so you had
it all figured out you had it kind of
like formulated right you had the
structure of it you moved out here you
had a place to live yeah it didn't
matter where you live that guy was a
dirty [ __ ] roommate but you didn't
say like oh I can't stay here
I could walk to Second City and I was a
six minute drive to The Comedy Store so
I was like oh I'm staying here the
rent's affordable like as far as La
standards go I'm like oh I'm here wow
yeah I stayed there for the first five
years that I lived there in the second
place
uh was five years when I moved in with
my wife to a new place and then the
place that we're at right now we've been
there almost a couple years so I'm a
creature habit once I once I like
something I commit to it as you is your
wife in the business as well or or no
she's uh yeah she's a social and
emotional learning specialist yeah yeah
God bless her man I think that's yeah
it's cool yeah no it's it's a special
calling yeah and then she has you know
she's a special needs person at home
with her too so yeah yeah they did think
they thought you were special needs
because you were that I was that bad at
that job they thought I was I am Sam
have you seen that movie yeah sure they
literally were like that's he's nice of
talking to us that's good yeah and what
was the first uh thing that you got
where you were out here the first thing
I got which allowed me to quit Starbucks
was a national Chevy Volt commercial
I know we've seen that one huh which one
is it uh it was they played back in the
day it was it was for the 2012 uh Chevy
Volt they played it it was like uh I was
a guy I had long hair that was like down
down to here I was sticking out of a
fast food drive through and uh a guys
I'm asking about his his car and I'm
asking him where he he pours the
electricity into his car and uh and then
I take a bite into his burger and he's
like is that my burger and I'm like I
just had to buy it oh wow yeah yeah and
just went to the audition yeah
wow changed my life
been doing comedy full time since 2012.
[ __ ] man that allowed me it paid my
bills for one year where I could start
hosting on the road and featuring on the
road and stuff like that back in the day
yeah and just doing enough just to get
by and then like since then yeah
obviously ups and downs over the years
but yeah like I've been very fortunate
what were the downs
where you don't I mean where you don't
know like where money's coming in at all
like where you're looking at your bank
account and it's just getting lower and
lower and lower and you're like rent's
due next month and would you would you
do I would just find odd jobs I would I
would Video Edit I would do random
things like during the day take weird
weird stand-up gigs like like around uh
I I did with a couple buddies we did a
15 year old's Armenian birthday party
it's just random weird gigs over the
years where we'd be like oh 150 bucks
yep we'll be there how much time we need
info gotta fill an hour okay we'll fill
it wow no [ __ ] man
and how were those good some of them
were surprisingly good some of them are
horrible wow but yeah
yeah luckily luckily I've had a good
crew of friends over the years where
you're kind of in the trenches you know
as you as you go along in your journey
if you make a good Core group of friends
then it makes it easier what was your
philosophy of doing the gigs like that
like did you worry you know what I had a
hard time
with [ __ ] doing parties like that
like one time I got to one where the guy
was going to pay a pretty good amount of
money I don't think I had gotten my that
wasn't on TV yet and it was in the 90s
and I pulled up to the place early and I
could hear him talking
and inside me I just said like nope and
I called that dude and I told him I got
in an accident I couldn't be there oh
but I was there early you you sensed the
the surroundings I was just afraid I
think um I was just afraid
yeah I uh I mean [ __ ] somebody that
looks goes full on head into that is
I've always been something to admire
I've been overly confident to a fault
where like even when I wasn't good at
all I'm like oh yeah I got this wow man
that's [ __ ] yeah and where does that
come from
it's counter to where [ __ ] comedians
are because they're afraid of everything
my mom
used to tell me that I was the best at
everything
and like I've just found out over the
years that I'm not just like by trial
and error you know like I used to think
that I was like a model dude I used to
think that I was like I used to think
that I I would look in the mirror and
I'd be like I'm the best looking person
on Earth because my mom built that kind
of confidence into me
I think there is something to do that
huh I guess never happened to me you
never you never looked in the mirror and
said my [ __ ] looks good on me
I used to like I used to think I was
going to be a professional NBA player
because you're wow I but I was decent
and then I went like but the as I got
you know older and like and more come
competitive I was like oh I'm not but
did your mom she was just that type of
person huh
yeah she just instilled that within like
me and my siblings let me think about
that think about you know most people
are like oh you know my mom or dad never
said they love me they never told me
they were proud of me they never told me
come here and you know have dinner with
us talk to us what's going on with you
right like
I it that doesn't just happen in one
generation that happens over Generations
so to find a parent that
takes an interest in you and really
makes you believe that anything is
possible is
a [ __ ] godsend she didn't have that
from her parents so I think that she
went the other way with it you know what
I mean it says a lot man you say that I
I didn't have that for my parents but I
look at one of my daughters and she's
like that encouraging her can tell them
how good they are and how nice they look
and how smart always positive uh
feedback and I know that didn't come
from us didn't come from it's got to be
really something I think you know to to
uh because usually you get to some point
where
you hear so much negativity that you'll
be like I'll show you but the idea of
somebody believing you from the
beginning and then you go out and you
really do believe you can do anything
yeah has got to be
it's got to be
to just less worry when you go out there
like you weren't afraid to go up you
weren't afraid to go to an audition you
weren't afraid and I think that's why
you got that stuff early on it's just
most actors are more people that go on
commercials are there never thinking
they're gonna get it right as opposed to
just going in and being there in the in
the present and thinking [ __ ] I'm good I
can get this the way I look I will look
at it I'm I'm a pretty happy guy like in
life and I'm grateful for like what I
have and everything the way I look at
them like if I don't get that thing like
I'm not hinging all this Hope on that
thing you know what I mean yeah because
like I feel like
desperation comes off real easily in
like and a lot of opportunities if you
want it too much and I've had to work on
a lot over the years because I'm a very
competitive person yeah I've had to tone
that down a little bit like as far as
like you know the industry because
people if you're too competitive then
people are like all right yeah easy
and you know I think people when people
are you know it when they're in the
industry and they're making decisions on
casting
or making decisions on who to hire
you know when you're on the outside you
look at the at the studio and you think
they got to be the best at their jobs
they're not
when people write a part they're writing
a part based on a story or based on an
idea three guys are sitting around in
the room we go okay he does this he's
going to meet a secretary she's going to
be a little bit nerdy and you put the
call out then these people come in but
there's so many places to go now that
not every job is filled by somebody
who's good at their job oh sure and you
think you would think that they were if
you went to the NBC casting or Warner
Bros casting that you think back in the
day there were there were less jobs now
there's all kinds there's [ __ ]
thousands of jobs yeah I'm I'm told I've
been told by some some friends in
casting over the years that they're
relieved when somebody comes in the room
that's good because they're like oh
because it's my job easier I don't have
to put out as much of a search they want
to find somebody you know when doing the
new show that we're doing we found a guy
that was a bit of a Woody Allen type guy
that would have been mine's partner in
the show at the point that you know the
father of her child and we all like them
he just very very kind of Woody
allen-ish you know good actor and then
NBC said no I think there's somebody out
there that's better and it was during
the pandemic so you had to zoom stuff
you know so
we found Matt Shively he was on he was
on vacation and the keys and he did the
zoom and when he read the first time and
he read another another scene and we
hung up and we went I think that's a guy
and we read him again he read with us
and he's the guy and he's [ __ ] great
and you can't imagine the direction of
the show without him there like he's so
funny man and I mean you're putting a
team together like on a show you want
everybody to be good yeah and and
sometimes they are and sometimes you
know the shows where you could give more
to one person and not much to somebody
else or the straight person
but they're good they're strong he's
good right yes he's gotten yeah he's got
his well he was already good but I mean
he's it's it's great to see somebody
that can be funny
and he'll find it himself which I think
is yeah so getting in yeah getting in
and and having somebody coming in and
knocking somebody out you leave the room
they go that's our guy yeah
you decide for your new your new show on
the way here I passed by a couple of
your Billboards yeah I think I am yeah
yeah you never really know what things
but I mean you know the it's been it's
been great everybody's really funny and
and uh we'll wait and see him
saw the commercials on TV and already
come on yeah they can hardly wait how
much did you get recognized after the
Netflix Bunch oh right all right and and
right now it's split 50 50 between the
Netflix thing and being with George sure
being on this thing yeah yeah half
people recognize me from this a lot of
people recognize me from Netflix
but you but you what you want to
be uh in the light I think I know it's
very nice for the first time in years
you know
the Netflix thing people are showing
appreciation for law enforcement which
is a dirty job right now there's nothing
there right and then being associated
with you this is a funny thing
everything is positive there's
absolutely nothing and who wouldn't want
to be seriously not
kissing blood out of your phone deal but
who wouldn't want to be associated with
someone of your comedians
[Laughter]
so it's all positive the one thing that
success gives you is less time to hate
people
now why do you have to hate anybody no
no but I I think um you know like the
first show nobody knew me you know the
20 years ago nobody knew me and I was
kind of like my introduction to
everybody and then now people know me
and then some people that you know they
I told a lot of people know me you know
but
I don't spend time thinking about who
likes me and who doesn't just do the job
or I don't spend or now because of uh
the work but I don't spend any time on
social media at all like I have somebody
that does it but I don't look at it at
all because I think that that
you know it's like porn let's say
you know I didn't look at any porn at
all yeah and then I was playing golf
with a guy and the guy was talking about
porn and I looked at something and then
I looked at it for years but I didn't
look at it before that so it's like when
somebody you look at something that I
didn't look at it but I didn't
then you look at it and then in whatever
part of your life you're looking at it
more but I think it it takes you away
from what's what's [ __ ] real
I mean I'm definitely jealous of that
you got to come up in when you did like
in comedy yeah of not having to deal
with social media I'm very like like
because it's something that it's like a
weird necessary evil that like we have
to use yes like the comics like that are
trying to come up and like make way
waves and stuff like that because
there's less auditions through typical
ways now where it's like the agent the
manager calling you like hey I got you
this a lot of the stuff that I get is
you know like maybe my manager
connecting something that I am already
doing on social media or something like
that so it's a weird thing so like I
would I would man I I can't wait till I
get to that place where I got it I got a
I gotta send a list of comedians
for an event that they're having and
they
wanted people
with
a large fault unless you're followers
yeah yeah so they said here's the here's
the list like do you see anybody on this
list
and they had their
um
number of followers by their name yeah I
mean what the [ __ ] man yeah that's very
typical dude you know where where
somebody's gonna get a part of two
actresses they're gonna give the part to
the actress who has the most followers
that's different yeah and it's a game
that you have to it's a game that you
have to play whether you want to or not
I on Tick Tock there was a guy that I
think he has an account where but he was
like saying that I had changed because I
had made money and that I have all this
millions of dollars and I pay no
attention to anybody else and that uh
I'm not humble anymore this [ __ ]
doesn't know me he doesn't know anything
about me it just and that's his thing
that's his angle is to tell people that
hey this guy is a sellout this guy has
got so much money he forgot about the
little people it's like
you think Jeff Bezos are [ __ ] people
gonna add you [ __ ] or sell
books in your garage and now you've got
more money you piece of [ __ ]
it's just I don't know I think it's just
people that
Envy is one of the deadly sins but but
also when your heart is in an area where
most people are abandoned
where your heart is in a place where you
spend time
pulling at people you don't know and
typing [ __ ] that's negative to people
you've never met yeah what does that say
about the about that person negativity
is always going to bring more eyeballs
and positivity yes that's why the news
is so depressing right and I think
negativity in someone's person in their
soul is that just you carry that [ __ ]
man you carry that around with you
everywhere I'm a positive person you
know and I S social media I had never
been on it and then I got on this
Instagram thing and
I answer every one of them
they're trying to get some panocha on
the side that's why no no I answer every
one of them and now
I got no negative ones oh yeah and I
laugh at them I don't care about them I
don't care I I don't respond to anything
I'm gracious to those and I and I just
told uh my family that I've got to I
don't want anybody out there to think
that I'm better than anybody I don't
want anybody think I'm arrogant I'll
never forget where I came from I'm just
Gill and now and so what if you do this
but the [ __ ] differences of making you
do well I just that's just not me I I
don't want to piss off anybody I don't I
I I'm I am so appreciative of where I am
in life and what's going on in my life I
I love what's going on I've been knocked
off of Instagram now they I thought it
was a 30 days
no no I swear I don't mess around I
accident maybe you had a [ __ ]
sandwich and your nuts were out somebody
somebody tried oh how did that happen I
know I got hacked I got hacked on my AOL
account I think somebody tried to hack
and that's what AOL which I have you
Charlie Chaplin [ __ ] AOL I know
I'm an old asaurus I still have it The
Man from Uncle yeah so I haven't so I
haven't been on and I don't miss it at
all I I'm drinking too much water you
got other things to worry about leaving
your concerns without [ __ ] manchas
over there yeah so I I don't I don't
miss it at all don't don't miss the
Instagram [ __ ] I haven't do you uh do
you but you you do podcasts right you do
yeah what's Bobby Lee's brother like is
he like Bobby Lee
he there's some similarities there uh
yeah Bobby Lee's like more of a like
Bobby Lee would get into someone's ass
like
you know like get back and have a war or
be like [ __ ] you [ __ ] you know
oh yeah well so yeah what's his brother
like uh he I say he I always say that
he's the best parts of Bobby
[Laughter]
how great was he when he came in here
Bobby
he was the first guy yeah the first time
I ever came on Bobby Lee was on and I
love Bobby Bobby was the first uh
comedian to take me on the road to let
me like open for him on the road he gave
me like one of my first breaks as far as
like like stand-up business stuff and uh
so yeah I have a podcast with his
brother called scissor Bros and we do
like a lot of weird challenges and and
wild stuff on that show what do you guys
do we've done I mean we've done uh a lot
of crazy stuff on that show uh have you
ever heard of Sir strumming never heard
of that fish
no it's a fish that's so potent that
it's illegal to come into the United
States it's uh something that they do
over in Sweden what do you mean it's so
it's supposed to open it under water
it's so potent it's so fermented in the
can and we accidentally opened it not
underwater and exploded all over my
garage and all of our faces and it stunk
for like two weeks
and we ate it it was oh oh yeah oh is it
good it's horrible no we're gagging
while we're doing it we had bones in our
mouths
we've uh we did a challenge we're the
first person to poop in a diaper one uh
you know we do weird weird fun stuff
like that we did a thing last week where
uh we shot
um AirSoft pellets at each other with
slingshots with high-powered slingshots
and they're they're hurt like it's from
here to over there we do yeah dumb stuff
like that
and how do people get to see that they
tell the people how they can watch
that's uh youtube.com scissorbros or you
can just type in scissor Bros on YouTube
and we got a lot of fun weird challenges
there we've like we're about to release
episode 82 so we've done a lot of oh
[ __ ] a lot of strange things let me ask
you this you want to be part of the show
look at this look at the guys that they
sent me
I figure you're you're
you should be on that list
yeah I know a lot of these it's an NBC
event I would love to and it's uh in a
bit with the launching of the show yeah
and influencers and all NBC people it is
really kind of like a showcase for
comedy that NBC asked me would I be
interested in allowing them to Showcase
comedians yeah off the launch of my show
and I said yeah and now they stand up
send me the names of The Comedians and
they're people that I know we just met
I said come on I would love to okay I
would love to
yeah I know a lot of the comics on that
list here type in your information and
then I'll put you in there okay
um what is your child do you have a boy
or girl a little boy and what's he into
he is in the garbage trucks right now he
loves garbage trucks
he's uh he loves Winnie the Pooh he
loves Jungle Book I love that stuff man
because you know what when when when
somebody is into
um stuff as a kid I think it stays with
the man you know what I mean yeah like
if you're into
um like
I just say like I liked
um
with cartoons how many Bugs Bunny and
all that stuff like you know I like that
I mean I didn't have a lot of stuff but
I liked
um you know uh uh I liked when I was a
kid and I would see an empty building or
an empty house we'd go into the house or
the building so I liked the idea of
what's the history of a building what's
the history of a house there was a house
in San Fernando that people ran out of
and we would go in there after school
hang out and and even growing up like I
spent a lot of time watching guys that
go on an abandoned you know house quests
and stuff like the [ __ ] that they find
into the Paranormal too but are you in a
paranormal stuff yeah yeah
are you yeah
are you nope
we should go ghost hunting together
George we should go go hunting come with
us come on have a ghost I have I had a
ghost in my house do you uh you know the
the the the the what do they call them
um
poltergeists were in there I think when
I moved in
and there was a lot of banging around
stuff and the first time I heard it I
just been there by myself and I heard
somebody go ma and I was like on a
Sunday night and I was like what the
[ __ ] and then every once in a while I
would hear ma but also I would hear
[ __ ] banging
banging yeah and I'm the only one in the
house you'd hear my footsteps running
out of your [ __ ] house yeah I mean
and we're talking about
and orbs in the house there's not as
many orbs in the house but we're talking
about [ __ ] banging like picking up an
end a side end table and just maybe a
couple inches off the ground and drop in
it so so not a door opening by the wind
but actual banging in an area of the on
the attic above the living room or in
that area one time somebody came and did
a doordash commercial during the
pandemic to give you know the waiters
more tips and the money goes to them and
we all kind of did a thing and the girl
that was in there
I saw her go like this you know and then
do that
and then she told a guy that was there
with me said tell George that in that
corner over there I could hear a woman
talking
really low
and I I believed it and I had somebody
come into the house and they said there
was a power there's like a closet by the
front door and they said
what the people that used to live here
alone did they have kids I said I don't
know if they had kids that go I think he
said I think they used to put those kids
in that closet over there like to punish
them don't any they said don't don't
ever close the door to that closet like
don't close the door
leave the door open
so the door's been open for [ __ ] it's
just freaking me out nine years they're
in my house I'm getting chills just
listen to this they're in my house you
know what creeps me out is uh we've had
this happen multiple times my wife and I
somebody will walk by my son this
happened multiple times now they'll walk
by my son and they go he's been here
before
I'm like what strangers have said this
to about our son freaks me out every
single time
he's been here before so like he has an
old soul or something like that about
him I I don't I don't know but it's a
very odd thing to say to somebody that
you don't know at all
so I upstairs I felt like
there was something going on in another
room and I would be watching TV and I
would
do that
and you're like man I [ __ ] feel like
there's something going on over there so
I did a video where I held a video like
this
and then when I brought it back
um
this face was in the lower corner
now see I
might my only Quest and why didn't you
hear me and here's the video
of the face so so this is in the lower
corner
and it moves out of the way
and it was on the it was on the it was
on the bed it was on the bed with me
uh see it move out of the way my
question is why what makes you stay
there
um
yeah moving is pretty bad
yeah it's that bad words you know what I
can uh so this is what I saw when I when
I that was the first frame of the video
it was in the lower corner so I thought
I thought it was in the other room
but it was in the low so I was I was
playing the guitar in the bed but I live
alone so once the day's over I go
upstairs I'm watching TV you're doing
this stuff and then I'm doing this and
I'm like
I do this over there and that head was
right here
next to me right next to me as somebody
that I knew that's somebody that I knew
the face of somebody that you knew yeah
who is it I can't say on the thing but
but it's like okay okay it was a friend
of mine so so the ones that and then
when the lady came in yeah and this is a
big thing like if people have things in
their house you know that people have
things in the house they feel things or
they see things I've never saw like an
old man sitting in a chair like like
somebody will say you know I'll come
down for coffee in the morning and I'll
look and there'll be an old man sitting
in that chair I haven't seen that [ __ ]
there's a lot of people that see that or
things fly off of the off of the table
I've not seen that but there's people
who have homes that listen remember if
you have a house there's people that
have lived there there's energy people
that have passed there's family members
that have passed you go to a funeral you
come home all this stuff is around you
or how close you were to somebody all
that stuff is around you so yeah
you're gonna hear some knocking at night
I'll hear it one time
yeah I'm [ __ ] gone the other night I
slept in the other room because that's
so much [ __ ] in one room and I was like
you know be traveling stuff I go lay in
the other room it's a very cool room
very peaceful I lay down and right
before I'm going to starting to go out I
I hear
and I'm going
somebody [ __ ] knocked and then you go
to sleep
and I'm like that's I'm by myself yeah
so yeah I'll go go swimming with you
yeah
let's do it mama wants to do a pair we
have a paranormal this guy in normal but
but
also there's people that there's people
that feel other people you know those
two like I like out of the Clairvoyance
or whatever the [ __ ] that but they can
say something to you and they'll be like
they'll be on they'll nail it there's a
guy AJ yeah that did that to some people
that he didn't know and the people
flipped out
they talked to these two guys these two
producers and we got on the we got on
the call and he says uh
he goes your father oh I see your father
he says your father passed right and
they said yes a couple years ago
um he wants me to tell you that you did
the right thing
and both guys start crying because what
what does that mean to you guys oh
um my father was on life support and my
and then the and then the father said it
was a tough decision but it was the
right thing so he said my mom did not
want us to disconnect the machine
but he was gone but my mom couldn't deal
with the fact that once you unplugged
the machine he's really gone even though
he was already gone the machine was
breathing for him keeping him alive and
he said to the kids because the the boy
is older they're grown men you did the
right thing
even though even though your mother
didn't agree with it thank you for doing
the right thing because I was I was gone
and I mean who knows that that a guy
that you're just meeting and I don't
know how that is too specific too
specific yeah and you know people that
you see or feelings that you get
intuition is all part of that when I was
working during the at night and I was
probably maybe 20 I used to work on
Friday nights I'm driving down I'm going
by myself up San Fernando Mission by
Sepulveda and I'm in my car and from the
restaurant up there it's just it's it
kind of goes down and there's one light
before you get to then the other lights
wait remember in the old days of [ __ ]
one light then a mile later there's
another light so cars would go not
necessarily cars would go fast but
as I started getting to the intersection
I felt like I needed to slow down even
though I had the green light
and I slowed down and a band with no
lights on went through the inner through
the red light about 120 miles an hour
and that would have T-boned me I would
have never saw it
and I slowed down for whatever reason
and I go I went to that intersection for
years you know uh 20 years living there
driving around there and I never slowed
down before and I just slowed down and I
went like this and this car is [ __ ]
found man just dark car [ __ ] through
the [ __ ] light about 120 downhill
straight downhill
and it's that kind of [ __ ] like that's
and and really only once it's not like
it's happened 10 times once but once at
an important time that guy would have
[ __ ] guy would have killed me yeah
once there's enough would it killed me
out have you seen anything
I I'm a little bit I haven't talked to
my wife about it we've kind of joked
about it we've we
've prayed in my son's room because we
don't know if if the room is haunted or
we just have a newborn
you know what I mean he's waking up at
all hours of the night yeah he's he he's
pointing at things basically [ __ ] yeah
they see [ __ ] that I do think that the
little kids see things yeah
yeah they're like a conduit to it
because they're so pure and that like
you want the blood I want the bleeding
the stuff from your oil come without
you'll be so puckered up
he's gonna be frozen
I go house hunting with you and I'm
packing I'm talking right now one night
I was getting into bed and uh you know
you get to the thing you're taking it
and I heard in this ear
in this ear
and I say out loud when I'm in the house
I say a lot I say I just heard somebody
say my name in my ear
and it's it's a trip
I was more afraid before we had the lady
come in and take all the evil ones out
and then you know we have an app those
ghost apps and then a [ __ ] ghost app
and we had it on downstairs and you know
it talks like that like that like a
computer
so we go down there and the Ghost says
my end
my daughter's name
and mama was with me I said turn that
[ __ ] thing off yeah
you know people play Ouija boards
I told my wife that stuff freaks me out
so much I said that's the only thing
that is non-negotiable with me I said we
are we're through if I come home and
you're with a friend and you're doing a
Ouija board and I came home once and our
power's out and she had candles on with
a friend and I thought she was doing a
Ouija board she goes it's not what it
looks like yeah yeah it's the most evil
and the fact that you can get one at a
drugstore or whatever don't [ __ ] around
with the Ouija boards yeah that's crazy
because you invite someone out yes but
you don't know how to put them you got
to put them back yeah
I a thousand percent agree with you on
that though black magic man like I
remember we do yeah of course you do it
so you have your hands on it you and
your friend have your hand on it and it
moves and you're like you [ __ ] moved
it I didn't move it and it it moves so
black magic you can get at a drugstore
yeah or at a at a you know at a toy
store at a Toy Story
yeah Spencer's Gifts random places like
that yeah
I'm gonna get you on this gig let's do
it all right okay cool
Jeremiah Watkins
thanks brother yeah
yeah let's plug the special yeah I got a
a one hour special that's on Amazon
Prime it's called the Jeremiah Watkins
family reunion uh the premise behind it
is uh my family surprised me and sat in
the front row and I walked out and my
mom and her new husband are stayed right
and my dad and his wife are stage left
and and my brother and his wife are in
the middle of the crowd and I'm
literally I just feel like I'm
surrounded by Family oh wow so it's an
interesting uh concept for sure that I
didn't plan on but uh yeah we is that
what is that what happened yeah I walked
out and I was completely shocked by by
what had happened they told me they were
coming to show I thought they were gonna
sit back in the room the club sat them
right up front but you know what that
okay I've been doing standard 42 years
I've NE talk about oh Nevers I've never
ever ever
heard of that it's so you are the first
one now now now we're gonna watch yeah
we're gonna watch anyways yeah but now
that you know this backstory of your
parents being on different sides well
yeah with their significance but not
together and part of the special what's
unique is I'm having slightly a
breakdown and I'm trying to manage my
jokes mixing with because my mom heckles
me at one part part of the show it's a
whole it's a whole thing it's a whole
can of work you weren't expecting that
no no
wow yeah Amazon Prime congratulations
that's big that's your first one yeah
yeah working on uh the next hour right
now I'm I'm uh we're shopping around the
next hour so yeah good man and you're
right you don't have any issues writing
you wish it down and write and yeah I'm
a guy who I ride on stage a lot I'm like
uh I I do um I improvise a lot on stage
and a lot of times I will end up
listening I'm really good about
listening back to my sets and pulling
the material from stuff that I said in
the moment and stuff like that and do
you ever go get them transcribed
uh there's different apps and stuff like
that that um but there's something that
I like about the repetition of listening
yeah and like writing it down and stuff
like that at some point you won't have
to you won't have enough time to write
them down yeah and then you can go get
them transcribed sure which I do I have
all this stuff transcribed yeah that's
cool I better went to Carlos Santana's
house and I said uh so what do you do
with the shows and you you record the
shows and he took me to a room like this
where they had every show that maybe
he's ever done art uh archived and
marked yeah on the walls so just like
wow and I you know I've been recording
my sets for as long as I can remember
you know I even you know used to go to
Circuit cities and when Olympus came out
with a micro a new micro cassette
recorder I would go get it and I
literally would pay like 250 I probably
had maybe a thousand dollars to my name
but I wouldn't I would go do that
because to me it was like investing in
the business yeah but and really spend
money on [ __ ] that you would be like I
mean you could really do this with a
[ __ ] forty dollar uh reporter but to
me that wasn't the thing wasn't good
enough yeah do you record on your phone
now uh no I haven't recorded through the
systems oh you plug in yeah that's even
better yeah so you can plug in yeah yeah
get the best quality that's great yeah
but one show that I did in San Francisco
at the punch line when they did like the
25 year anniversary of it it was on a
Sunday and I think I think I'd
at that well I went in there and was
really loose and the guy goes hey the
system we don't have it we didn't have
that I was like oh are you serious but
and rare like that almost like a rare
where you're so loose and just talking
do you like to get loose on stage inside
in a club like that yeah yeah I I write
on stage too I think you love my show
stand up on the spot it's a comedian I
invite my my close comedian friends to
do the shows and you go up with no
prepared material and you ask the
audience to yell out suggestions and
then you just Riff Off the audience
suggestions it's super fun
that's pretty good let's try again
all right girl you want to be all right
how about uh how what's what would they
what would they yell out uh it can be a
word it can be a first so let's let's
pretend girls on stage okay and you know
uh and you when somebody said okay so if
he was on stage what would he say all
right somebody's gonna yell out
something uh police chase
blue shares there you go I remember once
chasing this guy in a police chase he
turned one way I turned the other eye in
and Wrecking he got away I couldn't do
anything about it all right
yeah
and then and then he would be like uh
all right let me get another suggestion
and then it just keeps going I had to
stop I had blood coming out of my oil
hey yay we found it
after I forgot the I forgot the song of
it
all right brother congratulations on the
special we'll definitely watch thank you
very much I'm gonna send this number as
soon as I get out of here all right
sounds good thanks for having me for
coming in yeah